the way some states are prioritizing who
can get vaccinations is exacerbating the
national struggle to get doses
into more people's arms and to do it
more quickly
correspondent nisha hosni taking a look
tonight and what's behind the massive
delays
good evening aisha shannon good evening
the rollout resembling more of a
stumble and in states like new york it
could be because of all the red tape
it is the hottest ticket item since
beanie babies and yet states like new
york city
can't seem to hand out the covid vaccine
quick enough
out of the 8 million people living in
new york city
only 110 thousand have gotten the shot
governor andrew cuomo blaming hospitals
even threatening fines but
mayor bill de blasio calling on the
state to cut the red tape
why don't we stop talking about fines
and start talking about the freedom to
vaccinate
he wants to move to phase two now and
start vaccinating people over 75
people over 65 will have to wait till
phase three
behind teachers first responders even
transit workers
new york isn't the worst state though
michigan stands 44th
in the country for vaccine distribution
only 28 percent of the state's doses
have been given out
inviting some harsh criticism torrey
sachs with michigan rising action wrote
director gordon should resign from the
biden transition
team immediately to focus on
distributing the vaccine to michigan's
most vulnerable
but other parts of the country are
marching to a different beat
regular guy david mcmillan randomly got
a moderna shot at a d.c
grocery store when first responders
missed their appointment
the district's department of health
allowing vaccines to be given to anyone
if they're about to expire
and a northern california county broke
all the rules
when a rushed to give away 600 doses in
just
two hours after a freezer malfunctioned
in florida the rollout labeled a train
wreck by the mainstream media over
images of seniors camping out for the
shots
it was bad a little cold a little chilly
governor ron desantis getting into a
heated exchange with a cnn reporter
while trying to explain those lines the
state is not
dictating the hospital we distributed
vaccine to hospitals and
in the hospital said first come first
serve if you show up we'll do it
and shannon things are so dire here in
new york city the city council will hold
an oversight hearing next week to go
over whether the city is doing
everything it can
to roll out this vaccine as quickly and
safely
as possible shannon
hi shahasni in new york thank you very
much
and breaking tonight with the spread and
severity of covet 19 pushing the state
of california to the
edge a new order just out from the state
public health director is forcing
rationing of hospital care things like
elective surgeries
the state says the new health order is
designed to help preserve hospital
capacity to make sure that kovid
and emergency care patients can get the
care they need